papapapa pas pu te dis mais c'est
incroyable incroyable comment ils font
sur des engins qui font 30 mètres de
long ils volent sur l'eau c'est de
l'aéronautique aujourd'hui c'est un truc
de fou ils sont pour incroyable
lorsque j'étais pilote de rallye
j'aurais rêvé de pouvoir faire venir
tous les grands champions ici à la
martinique aujourd'hui grâce à cette
transat on aura ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui dans le monde en termes de
compétition sur l'eau avec trois ou
quatre catégories différentes et une
super bagarre donc ça pour moi c'est
déjà une très grande fierté que 2
recevra cette belle transat
vous imaginez ce que ça doit être que de
traverser l'atlantique avec des bolides
pareil doit avoir des moments
exceptionnels des moments très
difficiles des moments très forts avec
plein d'émotion que je suis vraiment en
grande admiration par rapport à cette
personne
la dynamique qui qui qui qui en
découlent c'est fabuleux enfin je veux
dire on a pour moi décrocher ce qu'on
cherchait depuis très très longtemps à
nous maintenant de faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour la conserver